it's fair to say faraday futures car is
one of the most talked about at CES and
you can see there's still a huge crowd
people here wanting to get eclipses of
it we're going to get an inside look
with Richard you're the designer of this
cars just pick out a few of your
favorite elements as we go for a walk
around the car and tell us how they came
into being yeah I mean the the front the
first thing you see from your rear-view
mirror will be this very slim
DRL and that's our signature look and
it's going to be a long flat horizontal
bar so that's the daytime running lights
down the cars right and it's very focus
is very minimal it looks like a machine
and what we really like here on the hood
is how this lidar it pops up and I don't
I find that it's it's quirky but it's so
so exciting you know when the first time
baingan Olson have the speakers that
popped up you said yes it sounds good
you know yeah we're level four yeah yeah
yeah and it's a beautiful cylinder it's
it's it's really a piece of industrial
design when that pops up you can
actually see past the a-pillars so
instead of having many of them all over
the front you should not not
cost-effective and not not necessarily
efficient right so you have one and it
looks 360 the wheel is is all metal and
then when when you when you want to go
to nice meet these carbon-fiber flaps
start to rotate aerodynamics this mirror
it's actually a camera and we we really
thought about being clever and future
proofing so in a country or state where
you need to have a mirror legally you
can take off that layer and bam you're
up in Asia you know they're a little bit
ahead but when the time comes we just
removed layers of screen inside that
shows you behind you look at your face
over there facial recognition so this B
pillar is an important part of the
design isn't it a central pillar of way
yeah and that's going to be your car now
or yeah exactly
if you look carefully that's your camera
no door handles just those two dots
there all this lighting here it changes
depending on the mode whether it's an
autonomous mode for parking by itself
and this way won't be on the back edge
so let's talk about the lighting we what
we like is this logo of ours is
integrated into all the crystals if you
if you have a concept around
jewelry like we did then you can play
with the depth of lighting in it and it
looks so so different from every view it
looks like it's from Tiffany's or SWAT
success